hello everyone and welcome back to
another video by simply learn my name is
anubhav and today I'll be talking about
charge GPT for web development and tell
you guys that you can create your own
website using charge GPT even if you
don't know how to code chargpt is an
advanced language model based on GPT 3.5
architecture and it can be incredibly
useful for web development projects but
before I tell you more about web
development with chargpt if you want to
become a software developer then
consider our postgraduate program by
Caltech in full stack web development by
simply learn and master those necessity
skills the link or to the course will be
in the description box below and pin
command you can also reach out to us on
the numbers that are given below and
learn more about the program
so let me tell you what charge GPT is
crgbt is a machine model that generates
human-like text responses it's been
generated on a massive data set of text
and can generate highly accurate
responses to a wide range of queries
but how can charge DPT be used for web
development
there are number of ways for example
charge gbt can generate website content
improving SEO and boosting engagement
chat GPT can also be used to create chat
boards that can interact with customers
in a natural and engaging way now let's
look at some of the real live examples
of how charge GPT has been used for web
development so for example if I ask rgbt
to create a e-commerce website for me it
will easily create it so let's see it
please create
a website
for me
in HTML
and CSS
so there is one point that I wanted to
tell you guys if you want to ask chargpt
for anything just give good description
about it so it can give you a good
response if I tell you tell it more
about my requirements it will generate
good quality of product okay so let me
tell it please create a website for me
in CSS and HTML
that should
some
like orange
and blue
right
and
where I'm selling
okay now lay wait for the response of
charge gbt it will create us
the things the code okay now it's
writing the HTML code right
so I'll tell you more about it like for
example e-commerce sites use charge GPT
to generate product descriptions
improving their SEO and driving sales
customer service team use rgbt to create
automated chat boards that can help
customers with common queries and there
are so many other things also like
content creators also use charity to
generate engaging content for their
website right so let's wait a couple of
minutes more until it gets completed
right so as you can see it's giving us a
proper response of everything
as it created this file for us
and we can just easily copy it from here
and I have logged into my online editor
you can open any editor if you want
so this is the online editor that I'm
working on right now I'll clean this
so as you can see
e-commerce website is ready right
so this is a very basic website but
charge gbt has created this for us
to an easy website like very basic but
as the instructions that I gave it it
applied all the things that it's using
yellow color but I asked for orange but
it's fine I asked for blue color
so this is also fine but before asking
charge apt you should know a little bit
about coding right so in H1 tag here
you have to write the heading is the
header tag inside that it's the H1 The
Heading one
okay so here I'll write my website name
I'll write website
and then you can see the train
website right
so how can you use chat jpt for your own
development projects first you have two
familiar yourself with the programming
languages and tools that are compatible
with chargeability and it will only
knows the data until 2021
so once you have done that you can
experience with chart GPT to see how it
can benefit your project
right if I ask him to create wait I'll
show you guys some of the things that
rgbt can do
create a header
so I have told rgbd to create a header
and make it functional and also add
page product page and contactless Page
make it a little more written make it
attractive right so let's see
it's will write us a code for that so
until then let me tell you the use cases
so as I already mentioned charge GPT has
already proven its value in various web
development scenarios
for example e-commerce platform use
charge APD to generate product
descriptions boosting their search
engine optimization and driving more
sales
customer service team employee charge
GPT to build interactive chat boards
that provides instant and accurate
responses to customer queries enhancing
the overall user experience
so optimize the generated content from
SEO ensures that the text generated by
charge GPT aligns with relevant keywords
and follow SEO based practices right so
with the help of charge GPT Su things
this can help improve your website
visibility in search engine results and
it can create natural and authentic chat
board experience so when using charge
GPD to develop chat boards focus on
creating conversation that feels like
human
use context and personalization to
ensure user engagement and build trust
leverage our GPT for customer engagement
Beyond generating content right charge
apt can help engage user on your website
also for instance you can use it to
develop interactivity and so many other
things okay so now let's see
what rgbt has created for us right let's
copy this
and paste it on the online editor that I
have showed you
I don't recommend using uh online editor
you can have a visual studio code it's
very good
so it doesn't have any CSS I guess yeah
I do customer custom styles for product
pages here yeah so as I know we have to
write the CSS here but it's fine I have
to show you something different so as I
told it to create the e-commerce website
so it give a given its name as welcome
to
e-commerce website but we can change it
from here the title of the website we
can change it right
and I have told it to create home
product and
contact page right as I have showed you
so it has created the same thing that I
have told charging video to create for
me as in the products page there's known
things added right now but we can add it
add your products and their details here
as it's written in the code also I guess
yeah in this section part we can add our
product and the things that we want
right now let's ask chargity to create
Circle
create five
server different
radius
or 20 pixels
to
your pixel
right and
print
files and
press blue and
Orange
now let's see whether it can create five
circles of different radius for us or
not
right and now it's writing a HTML file
for us
let's wait a couple of seconds to see
whether it can create so it given us the
things we want but I don't think so it
has
different uh radius okay as you can see
in the CSS part it is given everything a
different height and width let's copy
the CSS first or HTML anything you want
and we'll paste it on the online editor
let's go again and copy the HTML part
also and
paste it here now
we will
down and as you can see the first circle
is small and then the last one is the
largest one right so as you I have given
it the charge GPT the instructions that
I want this thing or that thing it has
created the same thing that I told him
to to right so it's all about
instructions but as I know that this is
width and height this is very simple
thing but when you will code on python
or JavaScript or Java it'll be a very
complex things so I recommend first
learn the language and then use
chargeability to improve it right so
many developers in programmers use share
digibility to enhance their productivity
not to learn it so it's very good for
learning purpose also if I tell it
I want to learn
Java is what I see
Java
from
where
should
start
learning it
gave me
some
princess
and
some
build
sides
from where
I can start
with the
Links of them
right so I asked charity to tell me from
where should I start learning the HD
Java so it's now telling that's great
Java is a popular programming language
as there are many resources available to
help you learn it here are some of the
website and resources where you can
start learning Java right
so it's giving me Oracle Java tutorials
it's very good to learn Java from Java
programming on core serum it's giving
some of the renowned Java certification
courses but I recommend you to take our
Java certification full stack Java
certification the link will be in the
description box for that it's a very
good certification for a newly starting
developer or programmer or experience
one also so from there you will start
learning Java from scratch so that is
also very good
you can also check it out right so as I
told it tools gave me the instructions
from how to learn Java so it just gave
me everything with the links right
so now
let's get to
give me any
projects ideas
for
react
yes
right
so now it's telling me
you can create a project on react for
from starting from to-do list which is a
very basic app when you start learning
any language you started by from Total
list only or to do app whatever you say
next one is weather app movie Library
which is also very good practice for
Library uh for react developers to start
learning reaction and the e-commerce
store it's a Founder chat application
and these are the 10 projects that they
the charge gbt told us to learn right so
it's very good you can ask it anything
if you don't know anything
foreign
I don't know I think
about react yes
please
about it
so I told it I don't know anything about
the ideas I know about the IGS but it's
like I want to see what it's saying you
can also check out the projects that I
have created on react on this similions
YouTube channel so so added saying
everything certainly real JS is a
popular JavaScript library for building
user interfaces it was developed by
Facebook and it is widely used for
building single page application it's a
dynamic application
so some of the key points of react
component based architecture virtual Dom
and declarative syntax unidirectional
data flow react Hooks and so many other
things so as you don't know in anything
about react it will tell you to get
started with react you can begin by
learning fundamentals of JavaScript and
familiarize yourself with HTML and CSS
once you have a good understanding of
these Technologies you can explore
react.js by following tutorials reading
documentation I recommend documentation
because it's very good you will get a
deep understanding of that then move to
tutorials and all and build small
projects it is also very good thing
start from learning from the project you
will learn more react official document
is here so Excel resource to learn react
yes from scratch additionally there are
various online courses tutorials and
YouTube channels dedicated to teaching
learning reactions such as reactors on
these platforms and you can also learn
react from our YouTube channel remember
to to practice regularly build projects
to refine U.S learning and leverage the
react.js community for support and
guidance working hours a major question
for several years I realized I was using
church
[Music]
and also I wanted to took the full stack
Java development course at cetera but
the cost was very good I have not only
learned Java what I've also learned
other Technologies I've been exposed to
emerging Technologies such as Dockers
test energy selenium Jenkins and I think
simpler lens course
helped me to go back to the pieces all
right not just that I'm not earning
three times more than what I've been
better and better
and it's because I'm always learning so
in conclusion child GPT offers
tremendous potential for web development
projects its ability to generate
human-like text response opens up new
possibilities for automation content
creation enhancing customer experience
and improving overall website
performance
I encourage you guys to explore rgbt and
experiment uh new things with its
capabilities in your own web development
endurance
so this brings us to the end of this
video on charge GPT for web development
we hope you had a lot to learn and if
you have any suggestions or doubt please
write them down in the comment section
below thank you so much for tuning in
today and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here